the bishop can start moving around the  it can redirect itself to another  diagonal yeah  oh i think this one is winning you know  i'm not even going to say anymore  i i think it should be winning but it's  not so simple funnily enough they're are  stalemate ideas all the time with  black's king in the corner when you're  defending put your king in the corner  at all levels just in case your opponent  is stable this one was a killer  lovely tactic  and a hundred on the bar and a lost  a handshake between the two fighters and  a big smile from chakria and mamadiaro  he wins  the match in blitz thai race to gain two  points a frustrating day for  jordan phanfories he was about to win  this match after  three games  but eventually it is  chakriyad who wins it all and let's head  out to sweden to hear reactions from our  two great fighters  great fighters absolutely we have